[Applause]
hey welcome to new project camp update
so we bought this piece of land are
living here with the binds of people of
grit and today in this video i'm going
to show you a day in the life here so
we're going to see the people and the
projects they're working on so let me
show you around here
and it's all going to be recorded in one
shot one take so
you would also see all the mistakes and
issues that come up but i think we'll be
okay
so first up is gonna be
the ruin we're renovating here we call
this the sketchy ruin because it's not
built very properly as you might have
seen in some previous youtube comments
but we plan to keep as much of the
original material as possible just for
the sake of reusing
so we're pushing a bit and the limit is
there of what is possible
so let's have a look inside we have to
enter here on our prototype
stairs let's catch you ruined so it fits
but watch out
so here we have adrian and martin that
are doing some
things
what are you guys doing what up dave we
are measuring the window to make the
frame make an inner frame of wood and
put all the insulation of the ring
because you made a little hole in here
to make a little hole for a little view
okay and how do you like the sketchy
room does it feel good feels super
stable super strong nothing to do with
the comments on youtube
i'm not sure if he's sarcastic or not
but okay well
good luck good luck good luck good luck
so we'll
continue our tour
up to the base camp
which is actually quite close by
and it's up there which is quite
convenient when renovating because we
need to get a lot of materials and tools
up here so we have a little pathway
emma is currently making stairs
because we didn't have a stairs before
but uh yeah we started falling with a
bunch of uh
materials and tools when dragging it
down so now it's more safe
hey
it's a stairs made from mimosa trees
which we have a lot around to it quite a
natural stairs
so
here we have the base camp set up
basically here
where we spend most of our time set up
in a bunch of shipping containers
but let's have a look
more closely maybe we'll start in the
kitchen
which is the shipping container right
there some solar panels on the roof that
power up everything
and some water coming from the well
there
which hita is currently using to water
the plants
let's see
hey rita
how's it going here
good good just watering
the garden because it's hot and dry
yeah
yeah but it rained a bit last night
finally maybe the weather is changing a
little bit
cool
and how is it growing here all good
planted this what last year
most of it yes
uh
yeah some new plants also this year
but yeah we try
to have a more permanent garden
cool and what is your favorite uh the
thing we planted
favorite thing we planted
[Music]
okay think about that we'll continue our
tour i'll ask later
okay
let's go into the kitchen
here's a nice place where we can sit
down
we usually store our cups here so we can
get a bit of water
all right into the kitchen
so here we have uh that preparing lunch
hey dad
hey dev
where are you cooking
um i'm working on a nice little soup uh
it's a little bit gonna be a bit of
funky combination some potato sweet
potato some tomato i'm gonna top it off
with some fresh basil from the garden
sounds like a tasty lunch
for sure
cool and what's the dish that people
like the most around here
well it's a bit complicated because
people like a lot of dishes but i would
say falafel is in the number one spot
i like falafel
okay and the least favorite thing
least favorite thing
i think green soup
we often get a lot of beans on the
neighbors and sometimes it's a bit too
much a bit too much greens too much
green soup okay but we're looking
forward to the falafel and the luncheon
looks good
uh okay let's continue our tour thank
you you're welcome
so
here we are in the back side of the
kitchen naomi should be somewhere here
because ziggy is walking there so she
can't be far now me
hey hey
she's mapping out all the native trees
uh on the land
uh how's the mapping going really good
really good cool
okay how many trees did we map so far uh
around 1500 now 1500 native trees on the
land that's good okay cool now you just
continue mapping uh around here how far
are we in the process really far
actually yeah i would say like maybe one
or one i have more hectares
just one and a half more hectares is
nothing okay thank you
so we continue here
to our pizza chill office area this is
our
multi-tool room everything happens here
and we currently have javier here doing
some computer stuff probably something
to do with video hi dave hi doing
yeah doing some video checking the shots
we did early
this morning
we're doing the waterfall that's going
to be coming in the following weeks so
yeah let's hope everything places on
time and we can make it a real nice
video update
so you're now editing the video of the
waterfall yeah is the video of the
waterfall it's quite a complicated space
to shoot but actually also you have some
nice views over there so
yeah i think people will like it cool do
you like the place
yeah i actually enjoy that a lot
also the food and people stuff yeah i
really like it
all right cool i actually meant the
waterfall but it's good to hear that you
like this place as well
cool all right thanks
so uh
now we're gonna have a look at another
little area we have also people like to
use it as an office
where we have emanuel he's italian also
stepped up our pizza game if you know
what i'm saying so here's currently uh
yeah what are you doing hey hi dave i'm
just working on the maps of the project
camp
and we had some drone footage
and we have made like uh drone maps
and i'm trying to take out some contour
lines from it
so actually if you
see
this is the map
and if i can zoom in
actually right now we are under those
mimosa trees
might be hard to see on the screen but i
see it very well from here looks cool eh
so it's a 3d model of the land yeah
all the land mapped by the drone and
also contour lines nice
all right cool how is it working in the
bushes
yeah right now is chill there's some
shades from the mimosa trees
and also we are
really lucky today we have some clouds
yeah very good huh yeah okay now is the
charging going you got some out of that
cork
cool
okay um
so this is more the area where we sleep
so here are the vans and the tents
it's basically just bedrooms because the
share things like cooking and showering
happens there so these are just boxes
where people sleep but let's have a look
in one of those vans
here we have uh emma in her van yes
hello
hey so this is your van this is my home
yeah cool build it yourself i did yeah
what do you what do you got on the roof
hanging there uh solar panel
everything is working on that
um
even the fridge yeah there's a rumor
going on that you guys have a freezer in
here i know i can show you
this ice ball
from the
pyrenees they have an ice ball in there
in their freezer they could have ice
cream but they have a nice ball so nice
it's so nice
yeah everyone has their own thing with
their van
okay yeah
cool yeah and do you happen to have a
mirror for us
yes i do
thank you
okay ciao
so um
yeah that is the area where we sleep
here is our little toilet
where what i guess you know what a
toilet does so it's right here
yeah people don't like it when you open
up the toilet when
when filming i don't know why
but yeah anyway another one here is what
we have who do you have here
steamo is the video maker shooting this
film
a bit overheating and a sour hand of
using the gimbal all the time
but we're almost done with the tour
because base camp is not that big
a base camp is actually just a small
part of the land and the land itself is
many more hectares but we spend most of
our time here so we have all the
facilities in a central place
so last cool thing to show is the
workspace which is set up in a shipping
container
so we have all our tools there and we
can lock them up safely so they also
protected from all the rain and humidity
and now we have uh martin in there
making something what are you making
well i'm making this window frame
for the big hole in the
sketchy rune
yeah and uh
how's it going
i'm preparing some cutting it's going
pretty well
just got my measurements and uh
yeah i'm soon gonna start cutting i'm
gonna try to make uh some nice joints
like this
to have a really sturdy window frame
it's gonna be a big window it's gonna be
a really big window so we need some good
joinery
cool
all right oh
wait one question how is it working in a
shipping container working in a shipping
container yes
it's it's great it's a really nice
shipping container we have everything
here
but
it's a bit hot and also because we have
everything here it gets a bit small
yeah it's a lot of stuff in a few square
meters but i guess we're gonna work on
that soon yes bigger workspace coming
hopefully
all right and then we can have a look
here
where
uh
julie we miss julie almost okay where
are you coming from
from the waterfall from the waterfall
are you cleaning it up
yeah on it how is it going almost done
because javier is editing the video oh
not only editing the video i heard
lunchtime okay but it's gonna be in time
for the video yeah okay good good
okay lunch time oh it does here we still
need to figure out what is her good tree
what is your favorite tree around here
look just this fig tree full of figs we
just planted one year ago
yeah i remember this coming in as a
little stick
and now you have fix coming in here
yeah this is doing well
i agree it's a good tree
okay now it's time for lunch
it's a good moment of the day
i guess
you know what it means to have lunch
it's always nice
so we come together on the table serve
the food
that that deliciously cooked in the
kitchen
and then
just eat
[Music]
i already have a spoon
got it
did all the big spoons come out
[Music]
all right yeah i think it's good
cool
[Applause]